back in the days uh by the way I've been
to Amazon for 16 years back then we had
five scientists within the company and
today it's in the thousands I came to
Scott science because Amazon supply
chain is one of the most complex and
technologically advanced Supply chains
in the world and I've had that the
problems that I would face here would be
some of the most challenging and complex
problems the scientists could
tackle and that's actually what I found
I think most people will expect a much
more sciency environment with writing
papers but that's not really how it
works in Academia we go forward from
possibility right we go forward from hey
here's the concept can be developed and
can we make it useful in Amazon we work
backwards here's the problem and what
scientific Concepts can we apply to
solve it I really wanted to make an
impact in real bird and Scott science
just like provides that I wanted to
still use the state of the art like
technology to build Solutions so this is
the perfect environment I would say and
I'm just like so happy with the decision
that I made what's amazing about
called science is that there is a lot of
expert knowledge and the work of us the
scientific Community is to formalize and
codify this expert judgment within some
rigorous models I was almost like a kid
in a candy store the the pace is much
faster than Academia and something that
I had a hand in within a few months of
joining was already implemented and we
were seeing the actual results and that
was that was very rewarding as well I'm
really interested in how Scott use data
to make smart supply chain decisions you
know like inventory planning labor
planning and buying and how this uh
supply chain decisions help Amazon
provide the best customer experience we
have particle physicists and biologists
and chemists we don't have enough
English Majors but I know there will be
tons of opportunities for me to
implement sophisticated models using big
data and really make critical supply
chain impact
we have a really strong science test
group presence here so it is really
amazing you just you know when you have
a question you can just like go up and
then like exchange ideas
Etc so uh this is a really uh great
environment for a scientist to be in
during my many years of working with
scientists and also managing mentoring
and building environment for them I
would say that they typically want three
things and be included number one is
really interesting problems
challenging interesting problems
intellectually stimulating number two is
an impact that you see immediately and
number three is also having a group of
scientists that you can actually bounce
ideas off as a science leader it's often
something that I think about how do we
Foster environment that every single
scientists have access to the to those
three aspects and have an opportunity to
grow
[Music]